♪
>> Jesse: IT'S BEEN THREE YEARS
SINCE JEFFREY EPSTEIN'S DEATH
BUT DETAILS ABOUT HIS UNDERAGED
SEXUAL BLACKMAIL RING UNDER LOCK
AND KEY.
BIGGEST SCANDAL IN AMERICAN
POLITICS AND STILL SO MUCH WE
DON'T KNOW.
"PRIMETIME" HAS FOUND NEW
EVIDENCE BURIED IN A TROVE OF
UNSEALED COURT DOCUMENTS,
INCLUDING VICTIM DEPOSITIONS
FROM A DEFAMATION LAWSUIT
AGAINST EPSTEIN MADAM GHISLAINE
MAXWELL.
THIS IS SARAH RANSOM.
SHE MET EPSTEIN WHEN SHE WAS A
22-YEAR-OLD ASPIRING MODEL,
TRYING TO MAKE IT IN NEW YORK.
LIKE SO MANY OTHER GIRLS, SHE
ENDED UP GETTING RAPED ON
EPSTEIN ISLAND.
>> THE MORE HE SAW YOU BEING
DAMAGED THE MORE HE ENJOYED IT,
THE MORE IT EXCITED HIM.
>> THIS AREA, YEAH, REMINDS ME
OF THE EVENING WHEN I TRIED TO
ESCAPE THE ISLAND AFTER I HAD
BEEN RAPED THREE TIMES THAT DAY.
HE WOULD DO THINGS.
[CRYING]
>> Jesse: SO HERE IS A PHOTO OF
THE ISLAND.
AND THIS WAS RIGHT AFTER SHE
SAYS EPSTEIN GAVE HER A NAKED
MASSAGE.
IN A SWORN DEPOSITION, RANSOM
DESCRIBED THE ISLAND LIKE A
BROTHEL WITH LOTS OF TEENS AND
GHISLAINE MAXWELL WAS TASKED
WITH HAVING ENOUGH GIRLS TO KEEP
UP WITH BE EPSTEIN'S SEXUAL
APPETITE.
WHEN I WAS FINISHED ANOTHER GIRL
WAS CALLED BY GHISLAINE AND WHEN
THEY HAD FINISHED ANOTHER GIRL
WAS CALLED.
RANSOM CONFIRMED THAT EPSTEIN
KEPT VIDEOTAPES OF HIGH PROFILE
MEN RAPING UNDERAGE THE GIRLS AS
SEXUAL BLACKMAIL.
HE SAYS SHE SAW SOME OF THOSE
SEX TAPING HERSELF EXPLAINING,
QUOTE:  WHEN MY FRIEND HAD
SEXUAL INTERCOURSE WITH BLANK,
AND BLANK, SEX TAPES WERE, IN
FACT, FILMED ON EACH OCCASION BY
JEFFREY.
SHE ALSO SAID EPSTEIN WAS
DELIVERY.
HE MADE SURE HE WASN'T IN THE
VIDEO SO IT COULDN'T HAVE BEEN
USED AGAINST HIM.
SHE SAYS SHE GOT HER HANDS ON
ONE OF THOSE VIDEOS AND BACKED
IT UP ON THOSE LITTLE THUMB
DRIVES AND SENT THEM TO
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS IN EUROPE
BECAUSE SHE'S SCARED SOMEONE
FROM EPSTEIN'S INNER CIRCLE
STILL COULD GET HER.
SO, IF SARAH HAS THE VIDEOS, THE
FBI HAS TO HAVE THEM TOO, RIGHT?
YET, THE ONLY ONE THAT'S BEEN
ARRESTED IS THE MADAM.
THERE'S ALL THESE HIGH PROFILE
VIDEOS COMMITTING STATUTORY
RAPE.
HOW COME NOTHING HAS COME FROM
THAT?
SOMETHING DOESN'T ADD UP HERE.
WE KNOW THE FBI LET EPSTEIN GET
AWAY WITH ABUSE FOR OVER A
DECADE.
THEY EVEN USED HIM AS AN
INFORMANT.
HE HELPED THEM WITH BEAR STEARNS
INVESTIGATION.
SO IS THE FBI COVERING FOR
EPSTEIN'S RICH AND POWERFUL
FRIENDS THAT ABUSED THE GIRLS?
ARE THEY BLACKMAILING PEOPLE
FROM THE TAPES FOR MORE
INFORMATION?
WE CAN O